last night i would i was shooting in the
desert
and on the way back home
i went to a panda express in palmdale
i'm sitting there eating and they don't
have to some places don't have eggplants
so it infuriates me i love it and when
you ask like we don't have it you know
they do have it they just want to cook
it because it's a separate thing they
don't leave it out there or it's not
even on the menu though oh really yeah
and i go oh you don't have the best
thing you guys make you [ __ ] idiots
it has it's that you don't use like 90
of the [ __ ] that you make is infused
with sugar
the honey walnut the orange chicken the
beijing beef it's just sweet you know
sweet meats sweet meats
so you know you want something like the
eggplant tofu because it's
it's savory it's there's no meat in it
it's delicious i love it if you're
listening from panda express right now
put it on your permanent [ __ ] menu
and taco bell the encharito put it back
on
you guys don't even know anything about
life i only taco bell i'm a grilled
stuffed burrito forever kind of gal
one of the original things on their menu
was this thing called the
to see this how can you look and
basically an entertainer is this
enchilada burrito it comes in a black
cylinder
and they still make it even though it's
not on the menu
it comes in a black cylinder it's
basically a bean burrito it's a wet
burrito yeah and they wet it with this
ranch sauce
oh so you eat it with a spork
this is pork you eat it with a spork and
every scoop is delicious
and then one day you go it's not even on
the [ __ ] menu anymore yeah cause they
do like seasonal like things no they
they do these cross you know promotional
things with doritos and they make you
know oh it's a that's why it's a ido
it's from the dorito no the enchanter
doesn't have that's burrito and
enchiladas yeah oh it is i was right
keto is not dorito
you know it's not doritos that's another
term either it's not doritos guys erito
is not er
yeah science alert yeah okay so what's
the the the dorito one
that's just well i don't eat those ones
because i know that they're cross you
know is it a taco shell made from
doritos yeah it's a it's a taco shell
that's a dorito but the top shaped in
the taco shell sounds delicious an aqua
shell just with some seasoning on it
it's not that good i think it's
it's definitely overrated oh so what
you're saying is that it can't it would
never be able to be um it's sell itself
as an actual channel it takes horrible
by itself just despite the tip at the
edge of it off yeah
why don't they try to actually make a
taco shell made out of an actual doritos
it's a fake edo then it's not even real
oh that's so sad it's heartbreaking del
taco yeah yeah you got to throw some
real idols in there del taco that's
where it's at um del taco yes especially
like we talked about the one in um
um
off of linwood in the middle you told us
a special one yeah yeah yeah it's not
the special one oh yeah it's the special
del taco yeah here are some things that
fast food joins that they don't you know
you have the mcdonald's that are the
king
you say mcdonald's no okay i will eat up
right i will go because right down on
western there's
you have breakfast 24 7. uh egg mcmuffin
so i if i'm super hungry and i desire it
at three in the morning i'll get an egg
muffin yup you don't need fast food
still
not as much but yeah not as much but
once a year but here in l.a here's the
fast foods that
or just in the country
the ones that don't get a lot of like
people don't talk about it as as often
arby's
oh yeah ooh arby's the five for five
when i first came to america the roast
beef
was
the best and i know their meat is light
purple it is i don't know if it's real
yeah it's pretty purple yeah if you look
at it in the light shiny it's a shiny
light purple
okay
and it and also um
and
it's pretty if you just get the without
che it's just a bull it's just bun
and like stringy meat yeah but you put
the sauce on it the horseradish sauce
yeah it's delicious yeah right they also
have jalapeno poppers delicious from
arby's yeah oh wow i didn't know that
the fries are nicely seasoned but here's
another fast food chain
that i go to sometimes baby
that people don't talk about
wienerschnitzel
i feel like people go to wiener
schnitzel they do do you go to we
international i'm vegetarian
i know
i've never been is that famous here
yeah they even have the little wiener
schnitzel car that drives around not
only that what you do is this don't they
have the pretzel thing there that's
really good that's the thing is that
every hot dog can be substituted the bun
with a pretzel bun
ooh
i'll tell you why the pretzel bun
is the king of all buns
i'll tell you why please
you can guess if you guess if you can
okay i okay yeah